good afternoon everyone my name is reto
Meier this is ian kneels and this is the
app clinic today welcome your transit
maps absolutely you know transit apps
one of the most popular categories
suggested by viewers after we asked for
suggestions and I think it's because
they're just so gosh darn useful they
really are I think that's the k2 this
and we saw we've got a lot of different
suggestions until we actually looks at
quite a lot of them and Nikki to adhere
is that they're really app stitch which
people are gonna use for to use a lot
off and certainly when I was back in the
UK public transport it's pretty much how
I got everywhere yeah but you wrote your
own right of course of course I wrote my
own because you know you had a couple
hours free I think everybody else was
drinking that day but awesome so we're
in the back of the bar writing
transitive well no this is the thing if
you spend an hour and a quarter every
day on your commute you have time to
write apps that's an excellent point
whereas I have no time to write apps
because I'm sitting there on the on the
101 just okay you've just dissipation
airy but it's frowned upon to have your
laptop open a while you're driving your
car I don't know why I don't know me
that we gotta get that self-driving car
think I think that's what's a guy was
thinking I just losing all of that time
so screw it i'll build the car the dress
for me that's right and the Batmobile
already had that built in exactly so
we're gonna do something a little bit
different today because we're reviewing
transit absent because they are so
incredibly useful for someone on the go
we're actually not looking at the tablet
versions of any of these apps which we
we almost never do with one of the
things that we really look for in most
apps is a good solid tablet layout but
we're not going to be checking that
today because i think there's a even on
the phone there's some things we can say
to almost all of these ABS absolutely
absolutely so let's go look at the
absolute which we are going to
investigate today these are the ones
we're going to look at offi in parking
london underground quick muni STM and be
london or in fact now it is the UK bus
checker see these are this I think what
all the most popular ones voted except
for the UK bus tracker which I threw in
because I kind of like the app okay see
I thought that we just had a huge over
representation in the UK that may be
coincidence it may have been ranked see
so let's so let's kick off like a look
at the first of the apps that we want to
look at which is often I think you've
had a little bit of a look at this one
yeah absolutely let's go ahead and take
a look at it is it off e is it a fee I
don't know idea alright so on my phone
now I have it running now the first
thing it asked me to do actually was
fine stations now we're here at our
headquarters at number 8 Downing Street
is showing so showing me for instance
that I can do 150 seven meters to get to
horse guards parade just waiting for the
edge fumble indeed I would never go
there it's it's it's a sad place 175
meters is going to take me to the
banqueting house I can get to Whitehall
and 239 meters of course that's that's
pretty close to 240 yards mmm thanks i
could throw a football an eighth of that
distance um so yeah and it's going to
show me from each of those stops where i
can get em I know it's got some
interesting filtering options it does
have a search thank God um and notice
that it's it is location where excellent
but of course you know this is a
relatively small print the list view has
the gradients behind it I don't know why
anyone does that it looks cheap yeah um
it's got some some interesting things
down here that I don't even know what I
think they're a disclaimers down along
the bottom
oh yeah yeah I'll see it on the screen
there i think it's a errors and
omissions accepted so i think they're
trying to get out of any liability for
telling you the wrong time stories you
miss your boss and feeling inclined to
six i work for so this this is nice
because if I especially if I'm used to
this transit system and I know the
colors and the numbers I can kind of
scroll through and see oh I can I could
catch any one of these buses near me I
can also get a directions from one point
to another so i go here and of course i
want to go to let's say take a dilly
because i know you're always hanging out
in it in the Trocadero just what i doing
it something so they used to have a
hookah bar that was amazing one yeah but
we really they let 16 year old kids
smoke there so it was mostly lollipops
good um and it seems to do a pretty good
job of getting directions show listen no
idea help style on the old song and
determinant update restaurant now here's
what i think is really interesting when
you get directions it gives you this
view which hopefully won't crash on me
the way it did last time but it'll show
you the different things that you could
take and the different times it'll get
you there yes so I think that's kind of
an interesting view now once you get a
route that has many options on it this
view gets really packed and it's very
difficult to use but it's it it's cool
now notice of course that they're not at
all holo theme they don't say they still
have the old skull menu button now for
those of you who watch the show I
frequently you've probably heard us
refer to this as the menu button of
shame this is the menu button of
slightly less chain degradation and no
that was this um because because at
least it does something oh except on
this anonymous yes Cyril is looking bad
guy yes it was shameful there
alright becoming a button of blushing
and let's shop and you guys it if you're
Daniel here Ian their viewers are having
trouble seeing the device so you could
just lower it and the camera view that
would be great indeed but you see I was
shaming them then I was shaming them
here okay I see ya yeah shingling but I
have lovely hands right okay right so
this whole thing doesn't work in and
modeling that's oddly enough that's what
I was that there's always of that up to
it not necessarily modeling um okay so
they do have the day of the maps as well
I didn't find this to be nearly as
interesting because it's not at all it's
not it's not a real mac it's kind of old
school scanning ad yeah and that brother
than but one thing that the this does
set this appt apart is that it has got a
lot of different networks available in
it and in fact if you if you happen to
go to a different city you can actually
now i'm not sure how I would do it i
think i would go to preferences yeah you
got a transport network you can see
they've actually covered a lot they've
got long-distance railroads in Europe
they've got a bunch in the UK they they
actually have San Francisco Tom and I
will say that when i booted this up
without my fake GPS this morning it give
me san francisco in san jose and it was
able to find the bus station closest to
my house alright so this
okay right does it look to it at the the
next step which we're gonna check out
and they see not just remind frequent
viewers that this is a little bit of
different we we felt like it might be
more interesting to go over all the apps
really quickly and then start talking
about their their deeper flaws in today
so we're going to go through spend about
two minutes on each of the apps that
we're going to look at checkout what
they do is sort of a functional review I
suppose with a little bit of commentary
on how they've done those things and
then we're going to spend more time
towards the end comparing and
contrasting seeing what they did right
what they did wrong and what we think
would make sort of the ultimate transit
app absolutely all of the stuff that
used to seeing will come just later
hopefully that will encourage people to
stay and work for longer but it could
also mean that they get bored and some
soon so please home dude so it's okay in
parking we're getting less boring as I
drink so that is as good a music I'm
sorry this is the one that I did look at
I'm more interested in seeing one yeah
so this was this was an interesting one
for me although I seem to have the the
wrong label up on the screen so there we
go in parking perfect so it took me a
little while to figure out exactly what
this app did which is probably my
biggest complaint you know I'm a big fan
of having apps which as soon as you load
them up it's pretty obvious what this
does how this is going to help you so I
kind of based on the name expected it to
help me find where i parked or something
similar turns out what it is of what I
think it is is a way to automate the
payment of parking so we have like
sms-based parking payment this app will
help you do that by automating the
process for you I think
which is where it gets a little
complicated so this is basically the
screen when you get when you first start
up only this is empty and so then you
can go when you click that and if it
what it lets you do is add your car
registration in the country which are
belongs to so it's just okay that's a
registration number country now again
this was kind of confusing because I
just put in us a bug her the Save button
appears is still great out and I felt do
anything there we don't even like save
buttons well indeed so I thought well
maybe it's just a legacy save button
which does nothing and if I hit back but
it hasn't actually saved what I've done
so that's that's confusing so I go back
in put my registration number hit
country again and now if I slowly start
typing United then I get the list and
then once I've got something standard
then i can hit save and it all works
kind of how you'd expect hmm ok only not
really that intuitive so it took me a
little while to figure out that workflow
so you can take this and then that's
going to be the default or the currently
selected car effectively so that's all
that's all fair enough but then I do
like the size of those touch targets by
the weather is nice and big that was my
biggest fan the biggest point of
happiness I guess using this happy that
everything is big this could actually be
bigger but still it's nice big targets
that I can hit one hand as
out of my car I do like that element to
it at that point it all becomes a little
bit more of a mystery all right okay
maybe I'm in Bulgaria well that
certainly makes sense something they you
know you've got a u.s. license plate in
the most likely place you would be
usable Gary oh of course so you would
think like what chances are that i may
be in which have a country the license
plate is full but you know i guess you
know Europe you could be traveling so
that'll make sense so okay now selected
the city that I'm in but again the
location awareness would have been nice
here you know what city i mean just
check and that should all be about all
right we'll have time we'll have time to
rip on it you're right you're right ok
so then eventually you hit this and you
get have to do it again hit it in my
hand and arrow no service i love that
because it's it's almost a toaster it's
not it's a customer for custome toast
yeah so again i presume that at this
point is when it would have sent the
message to the appropriate service to
pay for parking in the blue zone and
anyway I was sort of able to figure this
out was by going into settings and you
can see send em SMS eternally turned off
localization themes payment sent
notification so just sort of through
intuition else I want to figure out okay
so this works so it's an interesting app
if it actually works in the countries
where the parking is then I think they
might be useful but let's move on let's
move on to a quick meanie yeah I think
you had a look at quick meeting oh well
actually can't I just do the London ones
cuz i'm already in London oh that's sure
that's true I would have stopped it all
right let's uh let's let's do the show
the your the Bay Area native by native I
mean you've lived here longer than me uh
yeah but I live in San Jose which I
guess I live slightly closer exactly and
actually living in San Jose is further
away from San Francisco than really any
other major relative politan area
mostly because it takes longer to drive
there from San Jose then it doesn't fly
there or anywhere else in the world come
up here and also because San Jose is
that uncool Wow so we took down will you
leave man ten Jose's nice yeah we're
yesterday stories in San Jose well I get
me out your sometimes fun that's right
if I ever need a musk flavored piece of
licorice I know exactly where to go so I
see y'all gonna look at the limit on the
ground for other thing you know the no
yeah yeah the San Franciscan you sure
but I get the London Underground later
alright so quick muni is so one of the
things that's really confusing about san
francisco by the way is it has like
three different municipal transport
things and they they sort of inter
pregnant and I mean it's not as
confusing as Tokyo but it's still kind
of defeating so muni is the one that I
never take because it seems completely
useless but maybe it's just because i
always give somewhere else so what does
mean you take case we need the
underground or is me no no I think
muties like the trees yeah the trams
like they go down the bargain arrow
gotcha and see i would actually i would
take them down the embarcadero but
they're always completely full hmm this
isn't going to tell me if if it's
completely full but it will tell me
where now it's it's showing me nearby
which is which it was as close to me as
I was this morning when i booted the app
hey since uh seems to be a little stuff
this it's it does i'm actually kind of a
wondering if i should take this off of
Wi-Fi um but yeah so it'll it'll show me
which which stops are near me and then
it'll show me what the route is for that
stop and i am going to turn off Wi-Fi
because i think our our google Wi-Fi
here is just getting really crowded
okay so it'll show me that it'll show me
the route it doesn't appear to be
showing me just really give me the
information here yes I don't know what
the 56 must be the it's like the number
of the trip oh that's right yeah I mean
it certainly tells me that if I go to
the stop I I can Oh Steph to sculpt
number so we're going to stop 56 then I
can get the 1242 or 72 okay well that's
what I was wondering it the other way
you could interpret this is that I can
catch the 56 at executive park and I
would be able to transfer to these three
lines I'm not really certain I'd single
summer I think I I agree with you more
except it doesn't seem like 56 could
possibly be the stock number right hmm
or maybe these well okay so maybe these
are okay I think it's just the stump
right okay so there's just multiple
different routes coming off of that yes
I see okay in fact that we had to figure
that out is again it probably doesn't
mean that we're not natives right true I
guess that's one of the challenges when
you're creating a transit up like this
is that you've really got to audiences
you've got people who live there and
you're going to use this every day and
they really just want to see really
quickly you know things will change so
when is the next bus tram whatever going
to arrive I don't need to know about the
stops i just need to know how to get to
a particular place and your other
audiences visitors people who aren't
using it that often
to figure out how to get somewhere and
which which color bust I need to get on
to make that happen now this so I had
nearby have favorites that makes sense
and then I have look up now the truth is
I don't know why this is called look up
but it does seem to be something where I
can find out this is actually the most
you arrive right I think it works by
being able to go in and basically do
specific things so I'm going to get the
10 to Townsend in the outbound direction
and at the cancer Street stop and you'll
tell me when the next buses or tramps I
suppose it going to arise that's
actually what i would have to get is
very few or 90 play for a native ok and
and second uh well I can start that I
think that stars the stop though I'm not
sure that that actually stars yeah
doesn't seem to be stowing anything to
me yeah there we go okay let's find out
alright so I can yeah I guess what I'm
looking for here is just I mean we could
talk about this more later but I think
that this is a nice clean layout it's
just not completely clear how I'm going
to use this exactly it's it's one of
those things which I think a lot of
people you know I mentioned this sort of
two main use cases and this is an app
which those in between knows where
they're saying here is over the data we
have you can almost see the AP is living
behind this UI it's like we have an API
which lets you specify a line direction
and stop and I'll tell you when the next
one comes so that's a screen exact would
have an API which tells you sure the
stops are and which line stop there and
so that's a screen and that's kind of
the wrong way to
why you know you really want to think
more about what is the information that
you want to present users and come up
with that sure all right let's let's
move on quickly because I think we're a
little bit behind so gonna have a look
at the one that Underground's this is a
nice simple app which is handy for
traveling on an underground so I've
already been using it so we'll go back
to the main screen if I can so this is
an interesting challenge he saw straight
away that clicking on the home button
didn't take me to home it just left me
where it was and that's a little bit
confusing I always expect that if this
is a touch toilet it should take me back
to whatever home is right in fact has
probably the biggest or maybe this is
home well this is but this wasn't where
I was so if I go to let's see in flow
map information applications kind of
remember how I got to where I was before
I figure it out but see if I click here
hmm it's not taking me anywhere just
leaving right where I am so it looks
like an up affordance miss totally it
looks like a home screen button yeah you
know a shortcut to hide it even it's
even a touch tour it's needed exactly
that wasn't a touch hugs are sure so
navigation is the biggest problem I had
with the sound sort of figuring out it's
actually really functional but it's not
obvious how to get everywhere so the
main thing that you have here is that it
is a map of the london Lineker so you
know in London Underground is my
favorite subway system is that right it
absolutely is it's a clearly hadn't ever
lived in London indeed no I happen you
know what I've driven in London which
makes me appreciate the underground even
more that's fat that is fat so you can
say so you can basically go through and
see the map the famous London
Underground map works with with your you
know expected map ability just scroll
and zoom in and zoom out using gesture
support and all those sorts of things
you can add GPS which isn't going to
work very well here
and again Oakland is list right on waipo
you've got there you've got the fake JPS
yeah of course I i put my fake gps in
london today because obviously this
whole list is rigged so if i say locate
it should be able to hit you take you
some back hey the real there you want my
westminster so now the only thing i'd
say there is that you kind of got an
extra step there you know it's like
we've already said we want to and this
shouldn't say gps because gps is just
means global positioning system is kind
of meaningless it shouldn't say locate
me and then this shouldn't be this
two-step process it should just really i
would prefer that to be an action on the
action bar it's it's such an obvious it
seems like the first thing you're going
to want to do is go where in God's name
MI and then you can go here you can
click on this and it'll tell you how to
get to or from here from other places
you on the internet map minute map from
here the minute map is cool i like the
minimum yes I mean it's completely
useless really when it's la total lies
yeah but but what I love about this is
that I you know I could be a tourist in
London and just say well I've got half
an hour to spare what incredibly famous
station can I go to today exactly and if
you think you can get from Westminster
to wonder than 32 minutes during peak
hour then I have a bridge to sell you
but this one may be harder than New York
right now no probably there you go it
would probably work so that's quite nice
you can go through and you can do a
bunch of other things as well so if you
hit the I button again not the most
intuitive but what this is going to do
is take you to an iphone app which tells
you where what the service is like on in
each of the works and iPhone app I see
yeah it certainly doesn't look like an
interest yeah that's a pretty pretty
well done imitation and then exactly so
this is actually really useful if you if
you do use the on an underground
no English lines are in and out of
service is kind of vital and the
departure boards as well as nice it's a
shame that it's having to load all the
information every time would be kind of
nice but just preface I think you think
a lot of that can be cashed absolutely
and this actually well let's talk about
this yeah second exactly so that's
basically what it does shows you the
shows you the London Underground map and
tells you what the service is like on
each of the lines and when each of the
trains is going to arrive so pretty
useful stuff yes next on our agenda I
think we had STM this was this was asked
to be reviewed by someone who i think
has used it in anger and it just made
them angry oh yeah I hide all right i'll
tell you what i'll do STM but you gotta
let me do bus checkered too okay that's
fair that's fair okay so yeah STM is the
montreal transit app I it's I I don't
think it's quite as bad as some of these
honestly but you know it starts out with
well at least it's got the tabs on the
top I it'll show you where your your bus
and your Metro go has favorites it does
have a trip planner so I think now kind
of want it that's interesting so yeah
this Allah kind of non-standard icon
there it's just a person yeah i'm gonna
guess that the person is say almost
looks like the google street view icon
yeah so the Pegman it's almost the
Pegman right but then we'll just say i
don't know montreal
and I'm just oh nice well that that
doesn't work okay um let's see what it
does with that see haven't actually
selected your arrival point mmm oh I'm
sorry I cant cannot get us from London
to Montreal fighting but you would
assume that it can do yeah let's let's
just assume that he won the military I
may be no no there you go and then sits
got some general information now this is
uh oh that's interesting you see that
several other than Mach 8 yeah indeed
with the book that's probably took a
long time for something you know it kind
of reminds me of that old routine about
the women of this Snickers commercial
remember spoken hitch of poking at you
balls down below Paula Poundstone said
you know how however stupid you think
that commercial is somebody sat down
piece of paper and that's the way I feel
about some of these yeah you know it's
so much effort for we're talking about
like a week of work you like mark that
you might have gotten a bonus for that
from your boss and all it does is kind
of pissed people off now this one
doesn't piss me off very much in fact it
doesn't piss me off at all but it
probably wasn't necessary it would have
been nicer probably just to have the
taste yeah you could have more in fact I
think else I think our guidance is to
pick one right
four tabs you should either have an
image or have text not have breath so
yeah maybe a little okay of course this
is Canada um God knows there may be some
law but it required strip I would have
thought it would be language based
rather than cliff baby maybe it says you
can't you can't abbreviate information
to info because I don't know all right
the info is kind of boring it's just a
bunch of web pages so I think really the
only thing that's that's good about this
is the triplet triplet yeah that's
usually the key thing for something like
this and then of course you've got the
ah yeah uh interesting menu ob's got its
got fellas it's got an exit button yeah
we would be super excited about people
getting rid of these menus completely
because we're we're embarrassed about
them and we want them to go away yeah
but yeah this is not great it feels like
maybe it was developed on some random
different phone that had a completely
non standard colors game or no I think
that's the Achilles game it looks like
that's an attempt at branding which is
fine we like branding we like to have
apps which look unique which have their
own distinct look and feel but this I
think is going a little bit too far it's
a little quite a lot too far all right
that's a running a little bit out of
time so that's let's take a straight up
to the bus checker and okay from there
ok so bus checkers fun alright so bus
checker has some of the buttons that I
would kind of expect a course they're
they're located on a split action bar
and the action bar has to be split
because as you can see I I think this is
actually a standard action bar but the
logo here is just so
shouldn't be a logo at all in fact I
guess it could be it's a little bit odd
having so that really wide logo in there
having it and and yeah I jump on them
and nobody minds that on a on a tablet
here it looks a little weird Oh client
as well they have a pretty distinctive
logo as well you know I kind of tempted
to just stick with the logo approach
which is another approach in
particularly if it gives you the ability
to use the UH performance and those
sorts of navigation keys would think
that it doesn't yeah so so yeah we what
we'd love to have is just the icon here
with the affordance and then it would be
basically the icon followed by the word
map and then you know you can navigate
so map list that that makes a certain
amount of sense although this doesn't
actually want to go to live yes so
that's the it's interesting point you
have to have zoomed in closely enough
for it to have found a selection of
muscles before it will figure it to you
know now it does have locate action on
the action bar so that like sense so if
you have used a color here to indicate
that that's being used don't use colors
on the action bar says probably
something that I want to avoid right
today you go so now you can see all the
bus stops at a time I think actually
knowing that that's been used is a
relatively useless piece of information
yeah you can say that because you can
stay on the screen exactly that so it'll
it'll show me everything that's nearby
it'll show me that on the map it will
let me search not using a standard
search of films which is a shame because
throughout it doesn't look like there's
anything extra that you can do from
there that you wouldn't be able to do
from a in action about search no I well
there is this text here that I I could
read if I wasn't so terribly old true
it's very similar to but again that's
the sort of thing you can put in the
context it cell phone on this the search
bar
right right so um you know we'll go to
let's let's go to Wimbledon as you were
saying how's the advantage I goodness
that is the tiniest very small that's
not 48 pixels that is yeah anyway do it
go to the EV I could with the village oh
okay i think i went to the substation oh
is that just terrible I don't even want
to go to station out of town certainly
Bertha I have no idea what it's done
actually perhaps it's highlighted think
buddy else to a comment location at the
rooms so i would have to make you think
the rest this again no yeah that's a
nice it search yeah okay and once again
wimbledon chosen mostly because the
autocomplete will pick it up and some
time i'll go to the village because and
so it's interesting thing they've done
their own what I complaint is again so
we can get for free if they just use the
standard search right uh no it's not
taking you to one book no it's not but
then apparently neither just let it out
around as you're saying so I'll get you
then just not quickly uh alright so what
else can i doing that's so here's a and
this might everything useful I love this
you know it's basically it is the
interactive version of the sign that you
find next to every stop and most
metropolitan area absolutely so it's
going to
it's going to tell me when will these
you know where does this bus go when
will it arrive this is my favorite thing
LOL bus down national drag the boss then
you can follow their way let me let me
let it catch up here and then thank you
it's that these by the way this
shouldn't reflect on the app our network
in the android building is incredibly
unreliable because we have a million
phones in this building and they're all
doing all the wrong things absolutely
let's have a look so we actually click
on one of these this is so again this is
kind of non-standard the touch target is
really really hard to press this is kind
of my favorite bit in this is you're
getting up before where this is what you
see at each bus stop and here it's
telling me exactly when each of the each
of the process is going to come along so
some of the fancier newer bus stops and
london actually have this information
displayed on the board but having it in
the palm of my hand so that i know
whether or not i need to run for a bus
though I do have a policy of never
running for public transport because you
don't be that guy running after the
bathroom stop because they never stop
just like this up for me all the time
yes I have to be a secret alright so a
nice room yeah yeah it's I really like
this screen a lot it's very cool it's um
I'd like to see this movie prominent
it's kind of hard to get to and you know
one of the things that I think I think
we're just about ready to sort of talk
about the the prescriptions for what
makes for a great app and in fact I'm
going to pop that up on screen now so
one of the things which i think is
really important is it has to be usable
at a glance and not just usable as in
being able to see the information but
also being able to hit things while
you're walking down the street while
you're sort of hurrying for your boss
you want to be able to
get to the sorts of things oh really
easily yeah alright so oh I thought we
were going to be full screen but we're
not we're up there in the corner hello
what okay um yeah so this is you know
you want the most important things to be
right there absolutely and I think
you're right though with the London bus
thing--they it's a beautiful screen it's
really useful but it's not right there
why don't we go ahead and go through the
prescription ah alright yeah alright so
first I think it's always going to be
design guide compliance you know we want
all apps to comply with our design
guidelines and to be specific what we
want to see is consistency hmm so I
don't think that we've ever said that
you can't have your own UI but if you go
off in your own direction if you invent
your own stuff at least don't duplicate
the sorts of things that we've got oh
that's the magic button s okay let's see
I should have known better than to screw
with your system yeah I have a say I
reached over it laying the Kami was just
like you know the dude at the club
that's like hey DJ I can scratch better
than you now and like I'm that guy I'm
sorry it's all right yeah all right yeah
ed arias well anyway so the the point is
that you don't want to conflict with a
design guy exactly so if you go in your
own direction that's fine um some of
these apps likes things like in parking
is something which can have a pretty
unique look because you just you want to
have the big piece of information big
and prominent absolutely yeah i mean you
if you've got an app that just has a big
red button mmm then that might be
exactly what you need is your app is the
big red button it's really just about
trying to reduce the learning curve for
a new user who opens your app so that
they can figure it out without having to
figure it out now the mistake that a lot
of people make and this is what we won't
tolerate is the using your own UI but
actually it's a UI that someone in
cupertino doesn't
and we see that a lot with let's for
instance large agencies that are doing a
lot of cross-platform development you
know someone at the top you know
somebody's boss who just carries the
newest hipster phone yeah I will come
down and say hey this isn't the kind of
you I I'm expecting you know around some
of those corners let's get that Queen
background going and that's that's not
OK from our point of view because it's
not consistent with the other
applications on the Android device
remember you're not designing an app to
please people who carry an iphone
they're not going to see your Android
app unless someone shows it to them
while they're standing in line on a new
iphone right I what you want is to
please android users and Android users
know what Android phones are capable of
and what Android apps generally look
like and if nothing else they're used to
using the gmail app and the Maps app and
all the other Google Apps so in the
absence of other direction that's what
you should imitate is the google apps
absolutely but if you want to go in your
own direction that's fine just don't
conflict don't make something that looks
like an action bar it is an action bar
alright so the next one is location
where exactly so all of these apps based
around being able to catch public
transport somewhere near where you are
and so having them know where you are
without having to type it in yourself is
kind of a no-brainer I think most of the
apps we looked at today do this Pro
which is good so the real trick here is
is keeping track of your location and
doing so in a way those are going to
drain the battery so having the exact
precise location is not particularly
important to keep track of I think
really it's the sort of thing where you
open the app once get your current
location
and that should be enough for most
people um right yeah so a really good
example of this is the google now
application so you can see that when I
bring up Google now in my puted location
in London first it's going to tell me
that the time sensitive information to
know I need to be ready for that try to
games reviews yes that's coming right up
it's gonna give me the weather uh it
realizes them out of town hmm so it's
like oh you might want to know some
toast exactly how worthless US dollar is
exactly and I know what it's actually
giving you another than it used to be
yes and then yes um some rest prices you
only want to go where in the interim
yeah and if I had it set up correctly
who would actually show me the nearest
transit stops and when things are coming
upstairs I say this is the kind of model
you want to shoot for it it's as your
location it's giving you the relevant
information it's not asking you to
confirm its not asking you to to fit on
keeping the GPS Ronnie poner me right
the real point here is you could make a
circa nineteen eighty-five web app you
could well sir than 80 90 only 50 that
would be quite enough ya know but I look
at it but it'd be cool that would be
amazing yeah you can tell you 19 a 95 I
go for tomo you just mean point is you
could make a simple app you could make
an app that's obviously a nap or people
have to say I want you to do this mr.
computer or with all of the computing
power that you have a device like this
with all of the sensors and all of the
information that you have you could make
something that feels so magical it's a
feeling of magic it something we're
going to go on about week after week
it's really make it obvious make it easy
make someone open it up and go oh wow
cool this tells me when my next bus is
going to arrive
and it seems to know where i am and
which boss I want to take that's that's
kind of a magical experience the next to
a kind of go together sort of task
oriented and being news water glass
mentions to me earlier we were
discussing these apps and it's really
about thinking about when and how people
going to be using apps like this yeah I
was saying that you know when i'm using
transit out i'm usually on the go i'm
usually walking it's very frequently
cold often i have gloves on yeah I
exchanging them I may not have the
ability to read small text I almost
certainly don't have the ability to tap
small touch targets and so I want
something that's very usable without
having to parse a lot of information or
touch a lot of small stuff absolutely
you should have the the right
information should be there straight
away and navigation should be really
simple big touch targets a little
navigation as possible being able to hit
one button like hit the home button and
instantly be taken to what is most
likely the most useful information and
that's really the key about being task
oriented is what is the most useful
thing for me to see or do right now and
if you can't figure out what it is it's
fine to offer a few episode different
ideas but make everything circle around
tasks every now and then I might think
to myself oh it would be fun to just
browse the London bus schedule so that I
can imagine my future life is a homeless
person in London but in general what I
want is to find when the next bus is or
I want to find how to get from one point
to another I have these tasks that this
application can help me with and if it's
not obvious how to achieve those tasks
right away then I've got a lot larger
mental load I have to find what's the
closest station to me and then I have to
think to myself well where do I need to
go and
it was my time frame and I have to do
all of this work that the computer could
be doing for me it's important to note
as well but like these problems have
existed for a long time so there's
actually a fair amount of infrastructure
in place to solve this problem with ways
other than using your phone so as soon
as a user is going you know what it
would be easier to ask someone sitting
next to me when the next bus is coming
or like get up and walk around to see
what the sign says or tryin to cipher
the map on on the podium whatever you
want to create something which is easier
for users than what is already there for
them and that's not nothing well and
don't forget that unless you're in Seoul
google maps will actually do a better
job of this than many of the commercial
applications okay if you can't beat that
interface then your competitiveness is
in question absolutely and I think
that's a lot of what the benefit of a
lot of these apps bring is information
which you can't currently get under than
that so things like how long until the
next bus arrives let the Google Maps
offers that turning them in all
locations so that's a competitive
advantage and that's kind of what you
should be making as your primary front
page you know task uh what else we got
so efficient background update again
this is kind of an obvious one but one
way you you don't want to have to wait
for the for the app to update every time
we load it up it's obvious but it's
really difficult to your right a lot of
people do it right in general if you pop
up a dialogue that says updating you're
doing it wrong if you block your user
from doing something because you're
updating you're doing it wrong unless
you have a fully transactional system
where the atom icity of transactions is
imperative which you don't because
nobody does that on a phone then doing
that you're doing it now it's safer to
just let your user know that updates are
occurring and it might be very very
useful to give some idea of which data
that you're displaying is out of date or
which data is being currently updated or
about to be updated so that your user
can make a decision based on that
information but
in general if I see that the bus that
I'm waiting for that I expect to come in
20 minutes hasn't had an update for five
minutes pausing the entire program to
get that update is not useful knowing
that that information is a couple
minutes out of date is useful but not
the most important thing the most
important thing is to just keep the UI
responsive because as soon as you can't
do something you get frustrated and if
you can't do something for a stupid
reason you get really frustrated and
that's when I start on installing things
person I say last thing we want to
mention is a widget the seemed obvious
tonight like for anything where you
trying to keep track of when the next
something is having a really easy quick
way on the home screen so then you know
what is the workflow its hit the home
screen button the home button and there
it is that kind of seems like a
no-brainer so let's have a look so we
have actually spent far more time
talking about stuff than we necessarily
should have but what we want to do now
spend a couple of minutes looking at
each of these sort of details and in
reference to the apps so we should kind
of breeze through these in just a
competition so maybe one looks we
examples recap yeah so so when you why
don't you find that out so the first one
is designed about compliance and so for
those of you watching the place to go to
find the right way to do this is a
developer.android.com / design it's only
a bottom of the screen and let's have a
look so what you want to show maybe the
best example may be the worst example
under armour right there wasn't the best
example the boss chick was pretty boys
yeah uses a standard action bar oh I
probably would have gone with light
instead of dark you've got the light map
in fact this is pretty good guidance and
something would show Roman is mentioned
to us in the past which is unless you
are if you're creating something
immersive sand like video content with
people's supposed to be just looking at
the content they are not being
distracted by anything that's the right
time to use dark which is why I think
YouTube uses the the dark thing for
everything else lot is kind of a better
approach right so I think that would be
a good way to go here yeah especially
when when most of your UI is life oh
it's very jarring to have both types of
you I you know if you've got a night
mode for instance I think going dark is
fine so I think they really the only
thing they did wrong on this screen is
they should take out the bus checker
yeah and just a lonely okay I'm
absolutely icons fine and similarly I
think overall the navigation is a little
bit funny even the things on the action
bar as long as they all mean specific
actions that's fine I'd make sure that
the search button you know as an action
bar search touch targets and generally
tend to be then smell particularly on
the map view right on those there's the
dialogue which comes up a little bit of
the time to pick oh I mentioned us
specifically this list is beautiful this
is exactly what we're talking about when
we're talking about you I that's unique
but it doesn't conflict with our
guidelines right our guidelines I are
generally you know flat we don't like
gradients and lists why don't we like
gradients and lists well first off
because it's sort of the trademark of
different operating system but second
because honestly if you just slap the
same gradient down on every list item it
looks cheap it does it really I mean
it's been overdone yeah that's the thing
it was kind of overdone in the demo
scene back in the early 90s exactly
that's a long time ago it's the
everybody have fun tonight of absolute
graphics but yeah so but you can see
what they've done here is a beautiful
you know by color list plus this you
know little thing which it means nothing
but it was awesome it adds a Content
context to it which just looks
absolutely yeah and then then touch
target over here now the the value of
having dis as a touch target versus just
the
touch on the entire thing is a little
unclear to me yeah I'm probably Balu is
that given that it seems to be doing the
same thing it looks like they've gone oh
no man will hate on us if we have it
right chef on so we'll replace it with
something else right the actual solution
is to replace it with nothing right the
reason that we hate on rate Chevron's
isn't because well okay there's a lot of
reasons but the main reason is that list
items in Android are supposed to always
do something when you tap on them so you
shouldn't have to have an extra hint but
this is again this is a beautiful
display and a really good example of
what we're talking about earlier about
being able to build something which is
really custom there is nothing in
Android that's quite like this visual
representation of a bus stop sign even
with a little longer in the background
it's cute it's nice either it's
effective because although it is
probably not as absolutely fast as
having less mmm stuff you can just have
a list with each of the points but it's
not fun and people are used to this
right there is already an infrastructure
in place so the paper examine it brings
in the metaphor so that I know exactly
if there was if there was just a grid of
numbers here not only would be boring it
would be confusing I'd be asking myself
what are these things exactly yeah I
don't know which is stop what is it well
we know this already this and I know
exactly what's going on here this was
great so so this is really nice um and
the you know to use the favorites icon
so that I can I could save favorites
that's great it's perfect oh you'll
notice down here see it's refreshing in
nine seconds exactly this is a really
nice tip here so it tells you exactly
how first the daughter is how often it's
going to be in a resume we're gonna be
able to change that in the settings as
well okay so we're gonna we're gonna
have to speed up a little bit here when
I can spend any more time on design
because in fact Roman and the other
glass from New York and London the
design capitals of the world well we can
at least say what then I was the first
one ah wah probably probably STM I think
in terms of design I think that
had a lot of flaws just didn't look like
an Android app at all uh yeah um and and
just you know things like the scrolling
hey I just look want to use a little
more more thought now all right okay
location awareness again we will go to
Tennessee so I think most of these apps
did this reasonably well I think they
could have done a better job at perhaps
well l-serine don't have any location
awareness so it was really obvious
because okay I'm here's my tag plate I'm
in the USA oh now you want me to park in
Sofia yeah right i mean i don't want to
have to scroll down to see what the most
important it would be a little more
intelligent and basically that's what it
should be doing here is popping up the
screen saying this is where i think you
are this is the zone i think you're in
or indeed you're not in anywhere which
we support plan you know something to
help us out best way to by the way they
also lose points based on the great
ingredients and all sorts of other
things exactly so we've got a little URL
again at the bottom of the screen and
this is some of the location awareness
best practices so it's a blog post that
we put out I think about a year ago now
which basically explains how you can
find the current location of keep
location updates with while minimizing
your use of GPS and inherent battery
impact about us let's see if so the
other two we had a task orientation and
usable at a glance I think this is kind
of all the apps fall down a little bit
yeah you know in parking is not banned
in that it's if you figure out what it's
for this if you need it but the rest
they they kind of fall into this I've
got a giant list and you click on the
list and there's like so much
information yeah but they really you
know this is all good stuff to have but
you really want to break that down into
what are the specific tasks that I'm
looking for is it you know decide make a
decision for your app what is the most
useful thing why is it knowing when the
next bus is is it a trip planner is it a
map
figure out what the most useful thing
that your app does and focus your UI and
you use your experience around that one
particular task and and make it big make
it really obvious yeah I in fact this is
thing we've moved away from dashboard
style you eyes but I think that if
you've got something where it's supposed
to be usable by someone in a hurry and
there's two different tasks you could
use it for I wouldn't say no to having
some big buttons on the home screen yeah
but the important thing is just to make
sure that it or a viewpager you know
even you guys thank you perfect the
other thing is this is the based on your
current location this is the buses this
is when they're leaving you swipe across
and there's a trip planner swipe across
and it tells you want the what the
various routes are in that location
write something like so I think the
loser here is going to be quick meeting
because even though they use a view
pager was great I feel like it's a
little bit ineffective and we got nearby
we've got favorites that's fine so I
want to know where we're bus stops are
but then that's this logic eight right
ready this information right up front
this is where you are this is you know
you live or work based on your right
your current transits tell me how long
to my bus gets in right exactly and I I
was shocked shocked to find no location
awareness at all and it seems like the
first thing I would want in a lookup is
current yeah education that's and this
is not currently it's just that it's a
front-end onto somebody's webs that's
right this is this is totally web
service driven development I've work
service driven design which is not kind
of the right way to go background
updates I don't yeah we would probably
have to use these apps a little bit
longer but again most of them seem like
they are doing updates in real time
based on where i'm navigating to that's
not a bad approach but if you have a
look at the again the website that i've
linked here it'll tell you or it's
essentially an Android training class
which will tell you some techniques that
you can use to try and keep that
information a little bit fresher are we
are having too much of it
battery life yeah now bus checker i
think was that's because we were really
as well done some of the others were
popping up toasts they were popping up
modal dialogues you're doing all sorts
of things to take me away from the
application in order to let me know that
they were updating when I didn't care
about that's all just just have it
happen make sure that the daughter is
fresh and useful for me and give me an
ability to do a refresh if I want to
check you know right after than usual we
talked about widgets so there are two
apps which have widgets bring this phone
up so let's just kill something so that
is boss checker against the busjackers
doing a pretty good job here and this is
a think coffee yes nothing was the other
one cation visit this is again the
problem with these widgets again is that
they're a little bit busy a lot of text
in a small amount of space hard to
glance out when I'm walking along so
once cheshire actually really surprises
me because be compared to their out this
widget is ugly exactly and so you know
it was much about more an isolated
that's right so you know I think about
using some of those custom graphics that
they have to really soak the ridgid make
it through noticeable easy to use yep so
let me keep just about out of ya so I'm
going to bust through these things
before engineered and comes over and
throttles us both so we've got basically
each of the edge of the apps so avi gets
a couple of texts for the widget the
location awareness and parking is
location where reasonably usable to
clients which is nice quick meanie
pretty good in terms of the design
compliance viewpager action bar and
location awareness but not as much
location awareness as we could have one
wait a second yeah a quick meeting
wasn't location to where at all who made
these lessons no we need to get better
help london underground again reasonably
good and you can see but all of these
acts have done a couple of things right
but not too many and I think STM is the
clear loser its location aware and
that's about all we can say for it
and in the winter i think is probably
the UK bus tracker location awareness
efficient background updates a simple
widget kind of does the job the way we
would like to see it done alright so if
we can get us on the big screen say
goodbye to everyone give give the Friday
games review a chance to get in here and
get started so join us a 2 or 5 p.m.
interview we may be running a little bit
late also coming up on Tuesday Ronan
Adam and Nick from our new york and
london offices are going to be very
Android design and actually going to
take a look at three of the apps which
we review today and basically given me
ui/ux overhaul and show you the way they
think these out should look if they want
it to be really awesome now if you know
these guys these guys are incredible
designers that's why they live in New
York and London s'alright they couldn't
stand it here and they have they
promised to take at least one of these
apps and do a full makeover so it will
be it will be your home app makeover
show absolutely so that's a tuesday at
1030am new york time 3 30p in one min
time which is 730am here in Mountain
View Knossos we won't be there we won't
be there but we'll watch the video
thanks very much to engineer Dan fam and
to rate it we made the slides today yay
yay next week we're going to take a look
at tiny ass probably we haven't created
moderator page yet but keep an eye out
for the invite and have a look on
moderator you'll be able to nominate
more apps for us to look at in the
meantime we thank you very much for for
tuning in and watching I'm rado love you
and I will see you all next week goodbye
you